pierre laurent le secrétaire national du
parti communiste français est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous nous c'est-à-dire
lucile malandain de l' agence
france-presse et mickaël szames s de
public sénat
comme chaque semaine trois grandes
questions vous seront posées au cours de
cette émission première question manuel
valls peut-il aller jusqu'au bout comme
ils l'affirment sur la réforme du marché
du travail il rejette les critiques des
conservateurs donc comme vous en créez
dit-il dans le 19ème siècle deuxième
question votre divorce avec jean luc
mélenchon est il consommé des bisbilles
en effet vous êtes passé à la rupture
nette et franche sur la primaire de la
gauche
alors est ce également la fin du front
de gauche déjà fortement divisé et
secoué lors des dernières régionales
enfin troisième question que
réclamez-vous à l'union européenne
effectivement des pires laurent vous
demandera de vous mettre dans la peau
d'un david cameron si vous y parvenez
non pas sur le plan idéologique en tous
les cas lorsque les dix opéras tolga tu
as peut-être de la manière d' exiger un
certain nombre de choses à l'union
européenne
première question donc manuel valls eu
droit dans ses bottes convaincu de la
nécessité de réformer le marché du
travail malgré les oppositions de plus
en plus nombreuses cette pétition qui
recueille de plus en plus de signatures
en écoute premier ministre qui répondait
ce matin à un auditeur chef d'entreprise
prénommé laurent quand on assume les
responsabilités il faut aller jusqu'au
bout alors bien sûr laurent va y avoir
des discussions et les partenaires
sociaux et au parlement mais notre
définition du licenciement économique
comme le fait qu'on lève les freins à
l'embauché en réformant le barème des
indemnités prud'homale ces deux éléments
qui sont fondamentaux pour les
entreprises
laurent j'irai jusqu'au bout à leur père
leur rancoeur et pandev ou est ce qu'il
pourra aller jusqu'au bout selon vous je
ne le souhaite pas parce que tout le
discours de manuel valls repose sur un
mensonge qui consiste à dire si on met à
bas le code du travail on va on va
embaucher davantage on va créer des
emplois
or il faudra il a dit qu'il fallait
qu'ils
il devrait convaincre mais il a intérêt
à affûter ses arguments
parce que faudra nous expliquer comment
par exemple parce que ça fait partie du
projet de loi en faisant voler en éclats
tous qui encadre le temps de travail
donc en faisant travailler davantage
ceux qui ont un emploi puisque l'on va
on va permettre dans le projet de loi
d'aller jusqu'à quarante six heures par
semaine pendant 16 semaines consécutives
est ce qu'avec ça on va créer des
emplois alors qu'il ya déjà 5 millions
de chômeurs dans le pays
et beaucoup de jeunes qui sont en
formation et qui vont entrer sur le
marché du travail va vous ne le
souhaitez pas regretter pas qu'il aille
jusqu'au bout avec concrètement vous y
est ce que vous appelez à la riposte et
sous quelle forme
j'attends d'abord parce que c'est les
organisations syndicales qui sont en
première ligne dans cette dans cette
bataille elles sont elles sont en ce
moment même en réunion si elles prennent
des décisions d'actions nous serons nous
serons derrière les organisations
syndicales et moi j'appelle
effectivement j'ai moi même signé un
appel qui fait partie des appels qui
circule sur internet j'appelle d'ores et
déjà de toute façon à la mobilisation
sous toutes ses formes est déjà une
bataille d'explication parce qu'il faut
démontrer les mensonges qui sont
derrière le 10 mai à mort des syndicats
vous avez vu il ya un fait important
effectivement ils sont ce soir tous
réunis à la cgt avec avec la cfdt
vous espérez un front uni des syndicats
on n'a pas vu ça depuis longtemps bien
sûr que je l'espère parce qu'on a on a
besoin d'unité et ce qui est frappant
depuis la publication de la balle avant
projet de loi c'est l'ampleur de la
protestation en quelques jours des
pétitions en ligne qui sont couvertes de
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
signatures et des réactions d'hostilité
ou de mécontentement qui balaye très
très très large
au point que les seules encouragements
que j'ai entendu ces derniers jours
viennent uniquement deux du medef du
medef et de certains secteurs de la
droite puisque eric woerth a dit qu' il
aurait pu écrire le projet de loi donc
ça vient mairie on dit aujourd'hui qu'il
espère que le texte ira jusqu'à son
terme mais bien sûr puisque c'est c'est
en toutes lettres dans ce projet de loi
ce que
réclame le medef et la droite depuis des
années donc eu évidemment vont pousser
et même peut-être faire de la surenchère
alors vous vous contester l'efficacité
de ces mesures donc cela pour le cos et
c'est ce que prétend le gouvernement
l'exécutif des carburants qui veut aussi
faire de la pédagogie et qui veut tordre
le cou à certains mensonges ainsi
l'exécutif rappelle que le texte
s'inspire tout de même des propositions
de robert badinter fait que les grandes
mesures sociales sont maintenus il y a
toujours par exemple une durée du
travail le contrat de travail ne change
pas non mais pas du tout justement on se
sert du texte qui a été écrit par robert
badinter et quelques autres magistrats
pour soi-disant affirmé des grands
principes qui sera en préambule de la
loi mais tous les articles qui figurent
dans ce préambule c'est à chaque fois on
garantit tel principe mais il faudra que
ce soit sauf dérogations prévues par la
loi
or précisément tout le projet de loi qui
est derrière c'est un projet de loi qui
vident de leurs contenus tous les
principes qui sont affirmé manuel valls
lui sert que de que pour un espèce de
paravent pour cacher la réalité du
projet de loi alors l'une des réalités
de ce projet doit alors vous avez
peut-être pour le contester mais c'est
ce que met aussi en avant manuel valls
et que rien ne sera décidé sans l'accord
des salariés équipes qui devront voter
mais pas d'un scrutin sous l'égide de
savoir ce qu'on veut pas du tout pas du
tout justement assez encore à jour
cédant à faire absolument sur cette
affaire de consultation des salariés
il a fallu se battre pendant des années
pour faire reconnaître une chose
importante c'est qu'un accord dans une
entreprise ne peut rentrer en vigueur
que s'il n'est pas contraire au code du
travail
premièrement et deuxièmement que s'ils
recueillent un avis majoritaire des
organisations syndicales
ces deux garanties la vole en éclats
avec le projet de loi puisque dans le
premier cas on prévoit dans le projet de
loi des contrats
des accords d'entreprise qui pourrait
s'imposer se substituer au code du
travail
donc des accords dérogatoires au code du
travail que par ailleurs en ville de son
contenu et deuxièmement en cas
d'opposition majoritaire des
organisations syndicales mais on donne
la possibilité aux syndicats
minoritaires de réclamer un référendum
des salariés
c'est à dire et nous laisse indignation
face à mirecourt les syndicats sont
restés minoritaires à ces cons ils
représentatifs dans les entreprises
contournant leur donne la possibilité de
consulter tous les salariés jeu c'est
important quand même de comprendre que
la disposition a été introduite pour
contourner les accords majoritaires ou
le non accord majoritaire et d'ailleurs
vous savez comment cette affaire est
apparu
c'est le pdg de la fnac ça a été raconté
dans la presse et il n'a pas démenti
le pdg de la fnac qui racontait partout
que les salariés voulaient travailler le
dimanche
en vérité n'a pas obtenu le soutien des
salariés des jeunes déjà connus dans les
médias la ministre du travail sa cause
en disant il faut trouver un moyen de
déroger à cette situation et c'est comme
ça que cet article a été en trouver même
temps qu on peut écouter les chefs
d'entreprises aussi qu'est-ce que
maintenant les bien sûr eu besoin de
briller des emplois mais bien sûr qu'il
faut aussi écouter les chefs
d'entreprise et tous les acteurs de
l'entreprise et et moi j'ai le souci
justement du développement de l'emploi
et du développement de nos entreprises
mais je pense que dans la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes et tout ce qui
s'est fait depuis des années le montre
c'est que plus on fragilise les salariés
c'est à dire le travail et la qualité du
travail et bien plus finalement on
dégrade l'emploi au rang ce qui arrive à
avoir un emploi de plus en plus
corvéables et précaires et on ne permet
pas à tous les autres d'entrer sur le
marché du travail donc si on veut parler
créations d'emplois alors parlons
d'investissement parlons des moyens
publics que nous mettrons pas dans
l'investissement dans les grands travaux
dans le logement dans les transports
dont là on ferroviaire dans les
transports urbains
parlons de ces chantiers et emmanuel
valls rétorqué l'autre jour en alsace et
et hier d'ailleurs que c'est en
renvoyant ses détracteurs au 19e siècle
où santé mais la soneb les fous de la
charité l'hôpital qui se fout de la
charité mais parce que précisément si on
appliquait si on votait par malheur le
projet de loi n conneries alors là c'est
un retour sur tout ce qui a été
construit au fil des décennies pour
organiser une protection collective des
salariés devant les risques de la
précarité et du chômage
et en cette situation danser dans ces
temps de crise très dure
alors qu'aujourd'hui les chiffres
officiels le rapport de la fondation
abbé pierre la montre et on a atteint
maintenant 9 millions de gens en france
qui vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté et parmi eux de très nombreuses
personnes qui ont un travail mais un
travail qui à temps partiel un travail
précaire qui ne permet pas de vivre
eh bien on va ouvrir les vannes à une
précarité qui est déjà galopante et qui
va tirer le pays vers le bas et non pas
le sortir alors il ya bien d'autres maux
qui sont utilisés par exemple jean marie
le guen qui est en charge des relations
avec le avec le parlement il y fustige
lui vous est peut-être encore là vous
sentir visés et répondre il fustige les
grincheux les esprits chagrins eux mais
tout ça c'est des formules il faut
parler de la réalité de la loi parce que
le discours qui consiste à nous à nous
seriner à chaque fois que parce qu'on
met un projet de loi sur la table qui va
faire reculer les droits des salariés
eh ben on est moderne parce que c'est
vers ça que le monde évolue et bien moi
j'ai une autre conception de l'avenir je
pense que le 21e siècle doit être au
contraire un siècle où on se repose la
question du progrès social du commun
dans une société qui a été mondialisé
qui vit différemment mais qui justement
devrait nous conduire à nous poser
davantage le problème de la coopération
si on laisse le monde évoluer vers un
monde d'hyper concurrence telle qu on la
construit jusque-là dans la
mondialisation actuelle ça aboutit à
quoi a jeté les travailleurs les uns
contre les autres a jeté les peuples les
uns contre les autres a jeté les
migrants qui
puis la misère contre des gens qui
vivent déjà difficilement dans les
différents pays européens
qu'est ce que c'est que ce monde qu'on
essaye de nous vendre soi disant comme
un monde moderne c'est un monde de chaos
et un monde qui va conduire y compas
seulement la guerre économique mais
parfois même à la guerre tout court
alors moi je pense que si on veut penser
avec un peu de modernité le monde
eh bien il faut au contraire remettre à
l'ordre du jour le progrès humain et
lagarde manel valls a tout faux en
l'occurrence sur ce sujet là mais c'est
malheureusement une malheureusement son
occasion à peu près tous les sujets sur
tous les sujets il a tôt fait rouler
dessus mais je voudrais celui-là
particulièrement est un sujet très grave
et c'est pour ça que ça soulève un tel
émoi dans le pays je l'espère beaucoup
de mobilisation il a effectivement tout
faux sur toute la ligne alors justement
est ce que vous voyez avec ce texte qui
apporte et donc par là et myriam el
khomri est ce que voyait naître une
nouvelle fracture politique dans ce pays
qui va bien au delà celle des frondeurs
par exemple et la fracture est consommée
la fracture entre ses tics cette petite
équipe gouvernementale qui a fait sortir
petit à petit tous les ministres avaient
là il y en a d'autres qui change au
parlement la qui on a parlé d'un
élargissement ou non mais ça n'est pas
un élargissement c'est un gouvernement
qui n'a fait depuis cinq ans qu'une
seule chose c'est se rétrécir petit à
petit et qui a dû sortir de ce
gouvernement tout ce qui m était une
voix un peu différente et qui pourtant
pendant les premières années ont essayé
de s'accrocher de soutenir le
gouvernement et il y en a aujourd'hui un
petit clan gouvernementale qui persiste
sur une ligne qui est rejeté par en
parler maintenant un clan oui un clan
gouvernementale autour de françois
hollande avec quelques ministres qui qui
qui sont restés dans le soutien au tour
de manuel valls
mais les forces vives
sociale et les forces vives de l'agout
et la gauche sont ailleurs maîtriser ma
le gouvernement nous ne sommes plus
gouvernée par la gauche nous sommes
gouvernés par une petite équipe autour
de hollande et de valls qui mène une
politique lente et kiwis et qui n'a plus
rien à voir avec les électeurs de gauche
qui avait porté ce pouvoir alors le
débat est quand même ouvert a dit le
premier ministre et son texte est d'avis
que le texte allait être débattue il ya
sur le parlement va jouer son rôle et si
le gouvernement
il va s'en occuper et que le parlement
puisse jouer ce rôle parce que
évidemment tout le monde est revenu en
arrière très vite sur l'idée du 49-3
mais la simple idée que ça ait pu
traverser la tête de la ministre en
charge du texte de parler de ça avant
même qu'on connaisse le contenu du texte
entre quoi en dit long sur la confiance
quand même qu'ils ont dans les
parlementaires de leur maman il n'y a
pas de majorité de leur propre part vous
êtes convaincus vous aussi qui a pas de
majorité
peut-être sur ce texte aujourd'hui il
n'y a aucune majorité de oui est là pour
ce texte interdit et si elle 49 3 si les
hamonistes et s'il est adopté ce texte
il est
ça veut dire qu'il sera adopté avec des
voix de droite c'est d'ores et déjà sur
ça et si le gouvernement fait appel aux
49 3 qu'est ce que vous faites vous
commune et bien moi je proposerai à
l'ensemble des parlementaires de gauche
effectivement de voter une censure on
voterait la sensuelle jeudi je
proposerai puisque nous n'avons pas les
moyens oui de déposer une motion et bien
sûr sommes pas suffisamment
donc je proposerai à des parlementaires
à ce moment-là de gauche de gauche qui
ce qui serait opposé à cela de déposer
on se remet une censure alors vous
utilisez des mots forts depuis le début
de cette émission carré on vous parlait
d'un clan qui gouverne ce pays autour du
président de la république et qui n'est
pas de gauche et on va écouter françois
hollande justement il n'a pas pu dire
qu'il était de gauche l'autre soir sur
france inter il était interrogé par
nicolas demorand net vous encore de
gauche françois hollande
je suis président de la république je
suis revenu je reprends tous les
français maîtrisent évoquer mon parcours
ma vie mon engagement
mes choix sont toujours ceux qui
permettent de respecter l'égalité la
dignité humaine et le progrès mais vous
devez même si je veux faire des choix de
gauche aujourd'hui et je toute ma vie
est une vie d'un homme qui s'est engagé
à la gauche l'infiltré votre vie en 2012
et je suis devenu président de la
république je suis je suis toujours
engagé comme je l'étais mais je ne suis
plus un militant jeudi cet extrait dit
où le dit tout de la situation actuelle
il n'arrive pas à dire à dire je suis de
gauche comme si le fait d'être gauche de
gauche était un handicap pour
représenter la france et les français
mais il se le président de tous les
français et bien sûr mais ça c'est la
fonction qui l'obligé normal ça
n'empêche pas d'hier mais on peut on
peut assumer cette fonction est assumée
assumer ses convictions
d'autant que moi je considère que les
valeurs de gauche sont des valeurs qui
ont construit la devise républicaine
depuis la révolution française
donc elles quelles difficultés il y
aurait affirmé à affirmer ses
convictions commencé malheureusement si
je puis dire extrêmement cet extrait
malheureusement extrêmement révélateur
de la situation dans laquelle on trouve
alors comment est ce que vous comprenez
le pari d'une certaine manière de
françois lepetit lettres espérer être
réélu en 2017 si ils se coupent de la
gauche
si l'on suit votre démonstration mais je
l'en mais je pense que et je crois que
nous allons parler par la suite je pense
que justement il ne peut pas être le
représentant de la gauche à l'élection
présidentielle il est dit et si on
étendait et s'il prétend des lettres eh
bien il risquerait de conduire la gauche
à un échec majeur
il n'aime pas il ne doit pas se
représenter moi je crois qu'il ne doit
pas être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle au nom de la gauche ne
peut pas l'être
on se retrouvera dans une situation
indigne abri alors celui qui prétend
représenter la gauche devrait porter
pendant toute la campagne
la déchéance de nationalité et laudinas
taj du code du travail enfin on sait ce
n'est pas ça n'est pas compréhensible
pour pour personne pour personne de ceux
qui ont voulu porter la gauche vous le
ramener à un rôle de candidat de
figuration il a fait des choix
politiques tous pendant tout le
quinquennat
donc vous laisser vous disqualifie la
fed il a fait des choix politiques qui
ont été progressivement et de plus en
plus fortement à l'encontre de ce qui
était attendu
bien il n'a obtenu ni résultats en
matière de lutte contre le chômage
oui progrès social il n'a pas fait
avancer ski ski ski et les skis sont les
grands principes d'égalité pour le pays
il n'a pas porté là fortement la voix de
la france en europe pour faire évoluer
faire si elle est disqualifiée sur tous
les terrains anglais je pense je l' ai
déjà dit de très nombreux soit il est
effectivement disqualifié et il va et il
pourrait si on le laisse si on laissait
faire nous conduire à l'élimination pure
et simple de la gauche au deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle c'est à
dire on peut on risque de se retrouver
dans un scénario qui est celui que nous
voulons vivre dans plusieurs grandes
régions françaises
et moi je ne veux pour à aucun prix de
ce scénario et je cherche et cela
seulement à lens vous n'avez rien à dire
on va en parler dans 1 à 5 tout petit
avec interdire question est est ce que
jean luc mélenchon avait raison de dire
que françois hollande était pire que
nicolas sarkozy à vous écouter la
réponse est oui un g10 jamais vos jeunes
en jeu je n'emploie pas cette forme a
pour une raison très simple vous mènera
des limites a pour une raison très
simple mais c'est pas que nous portons
parce que sur cette question je suis
d'accord avec jean luc mélenchon sur
l'appréciation que nous portons sur le
bilan gouvernemental mais je n'emploie
pas cette formule pour une raison simple
c'est que je suis certain que si nicolas
sarkozy revient comme président de la
république puis il en rajoutera on va là
vous êtes à avrillé d'accord avec
l'exécutif combat et même je crois pas
une manière d'aider récolte mondiale
l'exécutif - genève adrien théaux n'ai
pas envie de préparer une élection
présidentielle pour choisir entre le
pire et le moins pas grave allez
deuxième question on peut avoir un peu
plus d'ambition ça en politique
deuxième question elle
donc nous porter vers la primaire de la
gauche et des écologistes que vous
défendez avec cette question que vient
vous posez lucile malandain de l' agence
france-presse
votre divorce avec jean luc mélenchon
est il consommé la primaire des gauche
et des écologistes donc vous divise en
écoute celui qui s'est déclaré candidat
en solo et qui vous fait la leçon c'est
le jeu de la toute la direction du parti
comme une quelques uns ont d'ailleurs
fait en tout cas certains violemment me
tire dessus à vue depuis que j'ai
proposé ma candidature je n'ai pas reçu
une balle venant du camp socialiste ou
ou de la droite etc
je n'en ai reçu exclusivement que d'une
poignée d'un quarteron de dirigeants qui
a toutes circonstances qu'on vienne sur
les mêmes mots alors premièrement pierre
laurent ne m'avait jamais parlé de son
intention d'aller dans les primaires ni
aux coordinations qui ont lieu tous les
lundis
c'est son bras droit monsieur olivier
dartigolles qui a annoncé à la radio que
le front de gauche était cliniquement
mort pierre a dit que peu à l'heure
actuelle il n'était pas candidat
bref nous étions repartis pour la
carabistouilles lisible habituel je veux
je veux pas je sais je sais pas donc moi
je dis jeu j'attends que pierre est fini
de jouer sa partie avec ses nouveaux
amis de la primaire et un jour il
reviendra à la raison et comprendra
qu'il est impossible de faire équipe
avec françois hollande
ces suppôts et les autres organisateurs
de la primaire car tenez vous bien sûr
40 personnes qui signent pour la paix la
primaire il y en a 38 qui étaient contre
nous en 2012 on qu'on peut prendre
meilleurs conseils qu auprès de gens qui
nous ont toujours combattu alors lucile
maladresse avec nos bons soirs alors la
question donc votre avis alors jean luc
mélenchon vous demande de cesser de
jouer 2
revenir à la raison alors le divorce
consommé cette foison mais ça n'est
absolument pas la question je n'ai pas
de commentaire à faire sur l'extrait
convient l'entendre parce que moi c'est
un ton que je n'emploie pas que je
n'emploie pas de manière générale et
encore moins avec avec des des amis avec
qui j'ai demandé la dernière campagne
présidentielle voulait reprocher ou non
mais parce que j'ai envie de
qualificatifs qui sont qui pourrait
envenimer la situation sané abstraction
du divorce comme vous dites ou pas entre
jean luc mélenchon n'est absolument pas
la question il y à une discussion
sérieuse à avoir et que nous avons
effectivement nous n'avons pas le même
avis sur cette question c'est que les
gens qui ne sont pas d'accord avec la
politique gouvernementale
aujourd'hui ils ne sont pas seulement
front de gauche avec jean-luc mélenchon
et moi même sont ils sont dans toute la
gauche
ils sont chez les écologistes et ils
sont dans une part grandissante du parti
socialiste est ce que nous essayons de
construire ensemble une candide un
projet et une candidature à l'élection
présidentielle pour éviter l'élimination
de la gauche est ce que nous essayons
faire ça moi je dis que il faut tout
faire pour essayer cela voilà et que 1
pour le faire
la meilleure manière de commencer c'est
pas que le front de gauche déclare sa
candidature et dire à tout le monde vous
vous ralliez à notre espèce et front de
gauche qui déclare sa candidature c'est
jean luc mélenchon tout cas une
candidature il faire du front gauche
puisque lui il a été le candidat du
front de gauche avec jean-luc mélenchon
ne peut pas dire qu'il part avec le
parti communiste
non mais c'est certain que cette
déclaration de candidature s'est faite
sans sans consultation sans consultation
du blues en partie au vivarium
communiste nous l'avons dit pas ou pas
du tout pour polir pot limité ou pour
tirer des balles
l'argent que mélenchon c'est des mots
qui sont totalement excessif
mais tout simplement pour que chacun le
sache parce que ça fait partie de la
réalité et du débat politique
j'aurais peut être la question c'est ce
n'est pas celle là la question et c'est
une question que moi j'adresse aussi un
jean luc mélenchon en lui disant il est
possible de revenir ensemble dans ce
travail collectif c'est une question que
je partage avec d'autres au front de
gauche parce que le parti communiste
n'est pas le seul à avoir des
interrogations sur cette candidature en
solo de jean luc mélenchon dont le front
de gauche et ensemble nous essayons de
dire essayons plutôt de lancer des
passerelles et jean luc mélenchon dit
une chose curieuse il dit il dit dans
l'appel de ceux qui ont lancé un appel à
la primaire il y à 38 personnes qui
avaient voté françois hollande au
premier tour mais précisément c'est
quelle est la situation c'est que
l'immense masse de ceux qui ont voté
françois hollande au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle envie d'un
autre choix
alors est ce que nous nous essayons avec
ces forces là de construire une
candidature ou pas
si nous ne le faisons je parle pour al
hazim invasion que jean luc mélenchon
pourrait revenir dans un processus
collectif renonçait à se présenter ce
que s'ils se lève voir bon sens et cela
met la pression sur lui s'est
sérieusement je pense que s'ils se lève
une dynamique citoyenne autour de cette
affaire ce qui n'est pas gagné parce que
évidemment si on présente le débat que
nous avons comme comme vous le faites un
peu la commune histoire de de tambouille
politicienne c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
intéresser les gens et ça les gens n'ont
absolument pas envie de ça et ils ont
mille fois raison moi ce que je veux et
c'est ce que j'ai proposé d'ailleurs à
ceux qui veulent une primaire c'est que
la première chose que nous fassions cela
n'est pas de nous mettre d'accord sur
une liste de candidats c'est qu'on
organise dans tout le pays pas de trois
débats des centaines des milliers de
déballer plus le plus proche possible et
qu'on invite tous les citoyens à
discuter de la situation dans laquelle
on est comment est ce qu'on va sortir de
cette situation et éviter le piège d'une
élection présidentielle on va nous dire
vous avez le choix entre la droite le
front national et une candidature qui
est celle du président de la république
sortant jean luc mélenchon va vous
rétorquer
il a déjà 60 de 1000 signatures des
groupes d'action qu'il y ait des gens
aux citoyens ils ont les anciens bureaux
repartiez hors appareils mais qu'il y
ait des gens qui soutiennent jean luc
mélenchon c'est bien normal puisque nous
avons ensemble fait campagne et 4
millions de personnes ont voté pour le
front gauche
ce que je dis moi c'est que même avec
les forces que nous avons accumulée dans
le front de gauche
elles ne sont pas suffisantes
aujourd'hui à relever le défi qui est
devant nous en 2017
et comme il y a des gens dans les autres
familles de la gauche qui sont
disponibles pour une construction
collective et qui eux aussi veulent un
autre projet une autre candidature que
celle de françois hollande
ça vaut le coup d'essayer de construire
ça et moi je dis dans les mois qui
viennent
consacrons ensemble d énergie à
construire ça on me dit ça va peut-être
pas marché c'est sûr si on n'essaye pas
ça va pas marcher mais moi je dis si on
essaye il ya une chance que ça réussisse
parce que je suis sûr que cette
construction peut aller au devant d'une
un trait gras leur désir d'unité de ces
gens et qu'ils ne veulent pas vivre une
nouvelle alors à propos de cette
primaire de gauche sinon pas de chez
paris maire de dole enfin jean-luc
mélenchon a argumenté en disant qu'il
n'en voulait pas parce qu'il ne peut pas
participer à une compétition dont
pourrait sortir vainqueur françois
hollande on est bien d'accord
vous même vous avez critiqué françois
hollande assez durement depuis le début
de cette émission permet en 6è donc
françois hollande est légitimée par
cette primaire vous allez vous ranger
derrière le chef de l'état sortant le
président abderrahmane baradat mais oui
mais tu as écouté ses extraordinaires la
manière dont on a de retourner les
choses moi je pose une question simple
qui est est-ce qu'on s'engage dans un
processus collectif pour essayer de
construire ça avec des gens qui veulent
éviter la politique gouvernementale
actuelle et sa réelle vous n'avez rien
contre le fait que françois hollande
soit 20,10 allemande à cette norme et
attendait manuel valls et françois
hollande parce qu'on pose souvent la
question on leur a posé la question de
la primaire vous connaissez la réponse
manuel valls a dit qu'il n'en voulait
pas et qu'il était hors de question de
participer à une primaire françois
hollande a été interrogé deux fois sur
la question il a refusé de répondre à la
loi le secrétaire national du parti
communiste qui pensent qu'il faut un
autre candidat
on va me demander de me mettre à genoux
pour dire non il faut absolument
françois hollande soit candidats dans
une primaire mais on se moque de qui moi
je dis je dis c'est que pour le moment
ce qu'il faut faire c'est organiser
cette primaire en donnant la parole aux
citoyens qui veulent autre chose qu'il
faut commencer par là qu'il faut faire
émerger un socle d'engagement commun qui
serait le point d'entrer dans la
primaire par exemple on dirait on va
s'occuper de telles questions de telles
questions de telles questions c'est sur
ça que doit organiser le débat parce que
c'est une aux exigences citoyennes que
vous soyez et dénis par jean luc
mélenchon ni par manuel valls qui est
chacun dans leur dans leur genre est
dans leur camp dit ce que la gauche et
irréconciliables et que cette médaille
la gauche chez qui la gauche
moi je pense que c'est pas manuel valls
qui va me donner des leçons de gauche la
gauche et des gens que je croise tous
les jours sur le terrain
certains ont voté jean luc mélenchon
comme moi en 2012
d'autres ont voté françois hollande au
premier tour d'autre voter eva joly et
on me dit ces gens sont irréconciliables
mais non ils ne sont pas
irréconciliables
parce que figurez vous que quand il ya
trois cent mille personnes en trois
jours qui signent la pétition en ligne
sur le code du travail
et bien moi je suis sûr que parmi eux il
ya des gens qui ont voté hollande il ya
des gens qui ont voté mélenchon il ya
des gens qu'on voter eva joly ou
d'autres candidats et donc les gens de
gauche ne sont pas irréconciliables et
même la question c'est quelle il se met
à nouveau ensemble pour éviter le piège
dans lequel on veut nous enfermer
alors il ya une personnalité à gauche
qui ne dépas non à la primaire à gauche
y compris avec françois hollande enfin
il aimait des conditions c'est jean
christophe cambadélis qui est tout à
fait récemment sur public sénat dans
territoires ddt info évoquait justement
vos bizzbee à gauche sur cette primaire
on les côtés vous réagissez à nouveau on
je crois que les uns et les autres
veulent que le périmètre de la primaire
son temps son organisation soit le plus
proche de ses positions à quoi ça tient
ou ça on arrivera à un compromis entre
l'automne et l'hiver ils devraient pas
beaucoup il n'y a pas un an qui passe
non bon donc on doit pouvoir se mettre
d'accord le hausse le ton
vis-à-vis du parti socialiste n'a rien à
voir avec la primaire il a tout à voir
avec la compétition entre monsieur
pierre laurent et jean-luc mélenchon
alors jean christophe cambadélis parle
de stratégie de mesquinerie de bisbilles
entre partis c'est ça la primaire c'est
pense que jean christophe cambadélis
n'est pas du tout le ton qui l'oncle
walt a un peu un peu comme ça arrogant
voilà n'est pas du tout à la hauteur de
la situation
la situation est grave dans le pays
elle est grave pour les gens elle est
grave parce que le gouvernement que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire monsieur
cambadélis soutien mais sur la table un
projet très inquiétant sur le code du
travail
donc jean christophe cambadélis devrait
se poser ces questions-là rimer et voir
comment ils y répondent plutôt que
d'essayer de jouer comme ça celui qui
donne des leçons ni l'exécutif ni le
chef du ps qui est quand même qui reste
le principal parti de gauche ne sont
vraiment d'accord comme comme vous dites
alors comment est ce que vous faites pas
organisé c'est une contradiction qui
existe dans le parti socialiste et que
moi je ne vais pas tranché à leur place
ce que je constate et c'est pour ça que
je crois ou un processus de primaires
c'est que de très très nombreux
socialistes et ça a commencé par tout ce
qu'on appelle la gauche du ps qui a
adopté une motion à l'unanimité fin
janvier alors que jean-christophe
cambadélis refusé de se prononcer pour
ce processus et ont dit banco parce
qu'il faut ré ouvrir le débat
donc moi ce que je constate c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est que de plus en plus de
deux socialistes est encore plus
d'électeurs socialistes de 2012 ont
envie de ce grand changement et n'ont
pas envie de retourner avec un candidat
qui a trahi toutes ses promesses à
l'élection de 2012
alors est ce qu est ce qu on donne de
l'espace à ce débat là est ce qu'on crée
un cadre qui va permettre à tous ces
gens de dire voilà nous les priorités
plongeon parce que c'est aux électeurs
de définir le mandat pas au pas au
candidat
nous sommes quand nous présentons à des
élections nous devons rendre compte
devant les électeurs
moi je dis à tous les électeurs de
gauche qui sont dégoûtés de la situation
actuelle c'est à vous de reprendre les
affaires au mans c'est à vous de vous
mêler de ce processus c'est à vous de
dire voilà quel doit être le mandat du
futur candidat qu'on aura et le candidat
on trouvera s'il ya des candidats qui
n'ont pas envie de ce mandat là eh bien
ils vont faire autre chose mais innovant
et bangoura mais justement martine aubry
demain de à participer enfin est donné
participant est en tout cas une réunion
des organisateurs de cette primaire à
gauche
est ce que par exemple martine aubry ce
serait quelqu'un derrière le jeu ne
collerait pas qu'est ce qu'il me sens un
casting avec martine aubry ses idées est
ce que vous pourriez ce que ça pourrait
correspondre
mais il y a beaucoup de choses qu'il
faudrait je discute avec martine aubry
parce qu'on n'a pas eu les mêmes
positions ces derniers temps mais
s'était dit dans quelle qu'elle fait
partie elle déjà dit plusieurs fois de
ceux qui n'ont pas partagé les choix
gouvernementaux dans la dernière dans la
dernière période tout en ayant fait des
compromis qui n'ont pas très bien marché
quand même au dernier congrès du parti
socialiste mais je le répète avant
d'être eux on aura le temps de régler le
problème de la candidature avant cela il
faut d'abord créer ces conditions là
effectivement les réunions qui se
tiennent celles qui sont organisées par
la peine couverts par les appels des
primaires celles que moi j'organise tous
les lundis au siège de notre parti qui
s'appelle les lundis de gauche
réunissent énormément de monde mais les
gens qui viennent avec plein de
questions plein de doutes plein de
méfiance ils veulent comprendre ce qui
peut se passer mais c'est normal mais
est-ce qu'on a une chance à ce débat
populaire et est ce qu on invite les
gens à avoir du pouvoir sur ce qui va se
passer
ou alors est ce qu'on leur dit
vous êtes des spectateurs les candidats
vont s'auto proclamer les uns après les
autres et puis vous aurez le droit de
choisir
et puis point final mais les gens ne
veulent plus que ça se passe comme ça en
politique surtout qu'ils viennent de
vivre cinq ans ou ce hoquet dans
lesquels ils avaient ils avaient donné
leur confiance ont trahi cette confiance
donc il faut construire un autre
processus s quel parti communiste
français est le seul en mesure
aujourd'hui matériellement je veux dire
d'organiser cette primaire que vous
appelez de vos voeux
parce que là vous avez tout dit non je
ne crois pas que nous soyons les ans
d'ailleurs dans mais je pense que
évidemment notre notre force militante
serait sera un atout indéniable parce
que nous restons à partie qui est
organisé sur tout le territoire avec des
gens qui ne sont prêts à dépenser
beaucoup de temps pour ça quand il ya
des élections normales
vous savez qu'il y avait ceux qui
tiennent les bureaux de vote sont des
employés de mairie mais aussi des
militants nous sommes présents nous dont
nous sommes capables en vous aidant à
des milliers de bureaux donc notre force
militante compterait beaucoup mais il ya
beaucoup d'autres gens il ya un d appel
parce qu'il ya plusieurs appels aux
primaires il y en a qui par exemple en
ce moment récole dit non veulent
organiser et qui récoltent les noms et
les adresses de gens qui sont prêts à
devenir des bénévoles de la primaire et
c'est cet appel là ils recueillent en ce
moment des centaines et des milliers de
gens qui disent nous on veut bien être
des bénévoles de la primaire donc moi je
crois que si on organisait sa il ya
plein de citoyens d'accord avec vous
j'ai encore une question sur qu'il avait
encore de rhamna jean luc mélenchon mais
elle porte sur la syrie la position pro
poutine qui a affiché ouvertement par
jean luc mélenchon est ce qu'elle vous
convient est-ce que vous la condamnée
est ce que vous estimez comme jean luc
mélenchon que c'est vladimir poutine qui
va nous libérer des djihadistes du
groupe
non mais moi je veux pas me prononcer
par rapport à jean luc mélenchon parce
que lui même a dit qu' on a trahi ses
propos tout ça au raca sur le sujet si
rien qu'en mai sur le sujet syrien oui
je pense que poutine pas plus que
d'autres puissances ne joue un rôle
positif dans cette affaire il a
justement un des drames que vit le
peuple
le drame que vit le peuple syrien c'est
que ce peuple est resté l'otage de la
lutte entre ce régime qui l'a d'abord
réprimer celui de bachar el-assad le
groupe d'âge qui s'est installée dans le
chaos de la guerre mais aussi les
grandes puissances qui entoure ce pays
et qui ont toutes joué avec le feu pour
défendre leurs propres intérêts et pas
l'avenir du peuple syrien et je pense
que si un processus de paix doit se
mettre en place et il est urgent il doit
se mettre en place
on obligeant ses grandes puissances à
revenir à la table de discussion
politique et à la paix et qu'ils cessent
les uns et les autres de continuer à
noyer ce pays sous un tapis de bombes
dernière question mais c'est sur le
thème les candidats de droite qui se
déclarent aujourd'hui le nouveau
candidat l art par exemple jean
christophe cambadélis a dit que c'était
le candidat le plus sérieux le plus
dangereux pardon à droite est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec lui écoutez moi
j'ai je lis les programmes des réseaux
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont tous assez
dangereux j'ai le les programmes
contenus dans non ce qu'on sait de
françois fillon d'alain juppé et et de
nicolas sarkozy sont extrêmement
inquiétant est celui de bruno le maire
aussi malheureusement ça risque d'être
une primaire à droite on va rivaliser de
surenchère ou vers des programmes
libéraux et des programmes qui emprunte
aussi sur les questions sociétales
beaucoup aux thèmes de l'extrême droite
donc ça risque d'être une primaire
inquiétante
c'est pour ça qu'on fasse il faut que
nous aussi on soit capable de faire
preuve de rassemblement merci lui si le
troisième parti de rémy sur la troisième
question et qu'elle va vous poser
michaël szames est-ce que réclamez-vous
à l'union européenne vaut 1 vous demande
donc de forcer votre nature je le disais
en remettant dans la forme en tout cas
dans la peau d'un david cameron qui a
donc réussi à se faire entendre des 27
pour une europe réforme et je pense que
le royaume uni serait plus fort dans une
europe réformer parce que nous ils vont
être leader d'une des plus grandes
formations du monde depuis l'intérieur
n'autorise aisée le choix est entre vos
mains
mes recommandations sont claires je
pense que le royaume uni sera plus en
sécurité
plus fort et plus riches dans une union
européenne
réformons je n'aime pas bruxelles
j'aime le royaume uni bonsoir mais quel
domaine saint michel mont saint père le
rond bonsoir
et vous vous aimez vos selles la ville
il ya des choses bien dans la ville mais
la commission de bruxelles et
l'orientation actuelle de l'union
européenne pas du tout donc un peu
d'ailleurs comme david cameron alors
savourer david cameron parce que ce qui
est allé demander david cameron à
bruxelles
c'est des dérogations sociales et des
libertés pour pratiquer le dumping
social un peu plus fortement dans son
nom son pays donc moi ma conception de
l'europe est inverse c'est à dire je
pense que le défaut d'europe actuelle
c'est qu'elle ne construit pas des
droits sociaux elle ne fait pas
progresser l'égalité en europe elle
organise les inégalités la concurrence
là où elle devrait faire progresser les
droits comment et les droits sociaux
vers le haut j'ai réussi à faire un
tendre le bras dans l'union européenne
est-ce que vous même ou ce que vous
proposez pour éventuellement cet ordre
de gauche comme vous souhaitez vous
seriez prêts aussi à faire tendre le
bras de l'union européenne
mais il faudra le faire parce que je
pense que ça n'est pas très étonnant
parce qu'on voit bien là dit la
différence de traitement pour les
puissants comme cameron
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé avec la
grèce c'est à dire la caractéristique de
l'union européenne actuelle c'est
qu'elle est faible avec les forts et
qu'elle est qu'elle est très dur avec
les faibles
donc ça s'est passé sans carnet avec la
grèce quand même oui mais non elle alors
oui si on fait les comptes depuis le
départ on a beaucoup plus tirée d'argent
de la grèce qu'on en a donné depuis le
début de la crise et on a fait payer au
peuple grec de manière extrêmement grave
la dette la dette des créanciers et et
des banques qui s'étaient endettés sur
le dos de la grèce
est ce que vous demandez vous au 6 mai
donc l'europe est une europe où les
pauvres de nos riches pour le moment et
pas l'inversé
contrairement à ce qu'on nous dit tous
les jours alors que mai mais moi j'ai
des choses
à mettre sur la table très important je
pense que la première chose à faire face
à la situation sociale extrêmement
inquiétante qui en europe c'est qu'il
faudrait changer immédiatement le cours
de la politique de la banque centrale
européenne stoppez les politiques
d'austérité et au contraire l'argent qui
était actuellement injectés par la
banque centrale européenne pour
renflouer les systèmes bancaires les
marchés financiers investir cet argent
dans des programmes de développement
socio- de l'europe qui permettent de
réduire les inégalités
il y à des inégalités considérables en
europe il faut les réduire il y en a à
l'intérieur des pays en a entre les pays
est il faut des programmes
d'investissement très important par
exemple dans le domaine des transports
dans le domaine du ferroviaire dans le
domaine de l'écologie dans le domaine du
logement et une seule morale des plans
juncker le logement le logement est un
problème qui se pose dans toute l'union
dans toute l'union européenne
il faudrait des programmes pour la
jeunesse mais bien plus ambitieux que le
plan young coeur on a mis les marbres
excite des repas pour aux contres comme
les anglais le demande
non mais il faut voter non mais il
faudrait que parce que vous souhaitez
une grande bretagne reste dans l'union
oui je souhaiterais la grande bretagne
reste dans l'union et jeu je pense et on
risque si haut si on n'y prend pas garde
d'assister parce qu'on a voulu maintenir
ses politiques libérales à toute force
on risque d'assister à ce que l'union
européenne vole en éclats mais on va
jeter comme ça les peuples les uns
contre les autres sans avoir trouvé de
solution défis qui sont posées mais
comment est-ce que je procéderai je
pense qu'il faut que la france engage
immédiatement mettre 10 à l'union
européenne
il y à un changement politique dans
notre pays et nous nous voulons
renégocier avec avec l'union renégocier
sa promesse et les premiers françois
hollande en donner
vous inquiète grâce à vos yeux dans la
peau et il a renoncé à faire
immédiatement après avoir été élu mais
je ferai remarquer sans aller aussi loin
que ce que je souhaitais c'est ce qui
vient de se passer avec le portugal
personne n'en parle je trouve ça
extrêmement étonnant parce que tout le
monde parle de la grande bretagne
personne ne parle de ce qui vient de se
passer au portugal il ya un gouvernement
au portugal qui est aujourd'hui un
gouvernement socialiste qui est soutenu
de manière parlementaire par les
communistes et par une autre
organisation gauche qui s'appelle le
bloco qui est membre du parti de la
gauche européenne que je préside et ils
viennent de faire de revenir aux 35
heures d'augmenter les salaires des
fonctionnaires et ils ont obtenu et ils
ont renégocié avec l'unodc le monial
encore tuer ou d'un froid il serait
impossible de l'envers seuil à la france
le faisait en en allant voir les
portugais les espagnols les grecs et en
dix ans ensemble
nous ne demandons dre ouvrir la
discussion sur ça n'allait rien n'aura
aucun poids
et quand même surseoir exemple
aujourd'hui il est allé en espagne il a
dit à pas des mots ce qu'il faut
désobéir à bruxelles sas et la marche la
bonne conduite des very redire non ok
qu'est ce que ça veut dire désobéir à ne
pas respecter les consignes oui ça veut
dire ça mais par exemple free par
exemple compte quand l'union européenne
nous demandent de déréglementer un peu
plus ou de privatiser un peu plus il
faut lui dire non et il faut faire la
démonstration en s'adossant à ce que ce
que souhaiterait notre peuple qu on ne
fera pas ça parce que ça a conduit à la
catastrophe
regardez ce qu'on a fait sur les paysans
on l'a accepté de déréguler tous les
prix et on nous a expliqué qu'avec sa
salle à aller mieux
et maintenant on est on est dans une
crise terrible et le ministre de
l'agriculture va à bruxelles
et il dit il est un peu tout ça mais on
a tout accepté ce qu'il aurait alors
fusé à ce moment là alors l'europe ce
sont aussi les migrants
la jungle merkel avec deux sons de
cloche au sein du gouvernement sur la
chancelière entre le premier ministre et
puis son prédécesseur qui est de retour
dans le gouvernement on écoute et vous
réagissez
l'europe la france et de l'allemagne ne
pourront pas accueillir tous les
réfugiés tous les demandeurs d'asile qui
viennent des conflits comme la série
face aux crises il faut faire preuve de
volonté et d'imagination
je pense en particulier à l'afflux
massif des réfugiés face auquel
l'allemagne et le peuple allemand
agissent avec un courage qui force le
respect des deux tiers raison talent bas
en l'occurrence je suis plus proche de
ce que dit jean marc ayrault que de ce
que dit manuel valls
je pense que face au drame qui celui de
la guerre dans tout le grand
moyen-orient nous dans lesquels nos
propres forces militaires sont engagés
et qui contribue à la fuite de de gens
qui sont massacrés par la guerre et qui
fuient ces conflits et donc qu'ils ont
droit à l'asile
eh bien je pense que l'europe devrait se
mobiliser toute entière mais mais c'est
un problème qui devrait être
effectivement traitée dans la solidarité
au plan européen est ce que vous êtes il
accueille des migrants qui le souhaitent
qu'ils soient de venir en france est ce
que vous seriez pour je pense qu'il faut
faire plusieurs choses il faut en tout
cas on accueillir beaucoup mobile au
maximum beaucoup plus bien sûr
aujourd'hui ça serait 30000 vous
souhaitez que se sont beaucoup plus
longs la france c'est un chiffre
ridicule ridicule on l'a français c'est
un chiffre indigne même par rapport à ce
qui se passe il y à des salariés
durement venir d'un autre pays
non mais ça c'est us est une autre
question si on nous dit qu'on va obliger
les migrants à aller dans tel ou tel
pays mais nous sommes dans une situation
qui est grave et qui équilibrent crise'
total par exemple nous disons nous
disons aux grecs au gouvernement grec et
alexis tsipras sa protester contre cette
attitude au dernier sommet européen
on dit aux grecs vous êtes la frontière
de l'europe c'est à vous de faire la
police dans votre seul pays sur les îles
grecques etc et débrouillez vous avec le
problème
et puis à l'intérieur de l'europe pour
ferme toutes les frontières et quand des
réfugiés
traverse la grèce il y à des pays qui
sont jusqu'au nord de la grèce qui
ferment leurs frontières à personne via
les frontières
vous parlez de frontières ce qui se
passe à calais aujourd'hui la belgique a
décidé de fermer temporairement mais
tempérament comme ses frontières avec la
france avec la france c'est la fin de
schengen mais on voit bien que cette
question elle est allée me schengen
émise en cause aujourd'hui par deux
traits là aujourd'hui on constate par
mansion mais d'abord par et puis et puis
d'abord il ya le problème de
l'angleterre qui ferme sa frontière
parce que qu'on est dans une situation
un groupe c l'angleterre qui ferme sa
frontière
mais qu'il va fermer au passé en accord
avec la france nous avons accepté là
c'est la belgique de telle manière que
la frontière elle est en france c'est
eux qui ferme les frontières mais la
frontière la dette en france
maintenant c'est la belgique cette
attitude allait scandaleuse parce que
face au drame de ces femmes et de ces
hommes qui ont été gelés jetés sur les
routes de l'exil par la guerre et qui
fuit dahesh que nous prétendons
nous-mêmes combattre et bien
effectivement si nous voulons traiter le
problème
il faut à l'échelle de l'europe un grand
plan d'accueil des réfugiés et il faut
le faire avec des moyens il faut
construire des centres d'accueil dans
dans les différents pays mais il faut un
plan européen pour ça et arrêter de se
jeter c'est de jeter sur les routes de
l'exil
ces pauvres malheureux d'un pays à
l'autre on va terminer les missions en
revenant sur le parti communiste
français et sur vos également si vous
êtes d'accord
on peut pas dire que le parti communiste
est enregistré de grands résultats
électoraux
ces dernières années on écoute ce qu'en
dit pascal perrineau rencontré il ya
quelques instants par et stéphane à
magnan et vous réagissez
ça fait longtemps que le parti
communisme qui a connu une forte
décroissance électorale n'a plus
beaucoup de capacité à se faire entendre
par le mouvement social par la société
française
c'était déjà le cas avec madame buffet
qui a qui étaient avant à la tête
également du parti communiste donc le
processus est un processus anciens c'est
le parti communiste en tant que tel le
message même du communisme aujourd'hui
qui ne parle plus beaucoup à la société
française et la faiblesse relative de
monsieur laurent la tête du parti
communiste et la faiblesse du communisme
en france et pas simplement la faiblesse
de monsieur pire l'an alors les
faiblesses à plusieurs niveaux donc si
on écoute pascal perrineau
vous avez dit récemment qu'il faudrait
quand même que monsieur perrineau change
de 10 parce qu'il lit ça fait longtemps
lui ça fait longtemps qu'il dit la même
chose et si vous voulez regarder d'un
peu plus près la réalité du parti
communiste le renouvellement de
générations qu'il traverse
ce qui est en train de se passer dans le
parti communiste et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui à gauche le parti qui est
le plus le plus dynamique et le plus
présent sur le terrain y compris avec
ses forces militantes celle parti
communiste on montera pascal gilbert il
ya le parti socialiste n'a qu'à regarder
leurs états à gauche il ya qu'
aujourd'hui
alors peut-être que le parti communiste
il a beaucoup de choses à changer c'est
le procès de choses que je pense qu'on
fait un congrès et on va à nouveau
changer des choses et améliorer notre
projet mais s'il ya un parti sur
laquelle la gauche peu con sur lequel la
gauche peut compter aujourd'hui c'est le
parti communiste
donc si on veut regarder un peu puisque
monsieur perrineau dit depuis longtemps
et c'est ce qui s'est passé depuis
longtemps c'est que aujourd'hui
justement dans une crise que traverse
l'ensemble de la gauche il ya une force
sur laquelle on peut compter c'est le
parti communiquer à leurs hommes pour
porter ces idées faut aussi une personne
et c'est vous et vous avez dit récemment
que
il faut forcer votre nature quand on
veut devenir un personnage public et
médiatique
c'est par devoir que vous le faites pas
rom non mais c'est moi j'aime beaucoup
ce que je fais
j'adore j'adore la politique et j'adore
la politique de proximité et ce que j'ai
dit dans l'interview auquel vous faites
allusion aux aidants libéralisme je
n'aime pas je n'aime pas le pouvoir
personnel et je manque messi et je
trouve que pour un communiste est
d'ailleurs d'une manière générale pour
quelqu'un qui fait de la politique c'est
plutôt une qualité de se méfier du
pouvoir personnel
alors c'est vrai que nous vivons dans
une vie politique et médiatique qui
personnalise tout et de ce point de vue
je dis oui je force ma nature parce que
moi je crois davantage et encore avoir
de la mare davantage au collectif au
travail collectif que à la mise en scène
personnelle et je pense que s'il ya
quelque chose qui ne va pas dans notre
vie démocratique c'est précisément ça
parce qu'une des choses ils ont pourri
la vie politique française oui c'est la
mise en scène présidentielle permanente
par exemple ou une femelle et quand elle
a dit pauline metteur en scène pour nous
est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
avez auxquelles vous pourriez songé mais
quand vous êtes effectivement quand vous
êtes obligés de vous mettre en scène et
que vous êtes présents eh ben vous
faites conseiller s'est tous évolué mal
vous fera seulement mais moi aussi je
conseille de ce type
parce qu'il faut le faire apprendre à
parler mais c'est dans les médias il
faut faire des choses comme ça et je
n'ai pas du tout ronde de ça ça n'est
pas le problème mais en même temps que
je fais ça et je ne suis déjà plus même
par rapport à ce que j' étais quand je
suis devenu secrétaire national du parti
communiste et je ne vais cesser de
m'améliorer je vous rassure
voilà b mais en même temps qu'ils que je
fais ça c'est vrai que moi j'alerte les
les citoyens auxquels je m'adresse vos
téléspectateurs et je le redis je le
redis ne vous laissez pas abuser par
toutes ces mises en scène par ce que
croyait davantage en votre force
collective et croyait davantage on la
sincérité et on la proximité de travail
des hommes politiques quand leur mise en
scène médiatique et jeu et en disant ça
je pense que je rends service à la
démocratie et vous lâcher
coup depuis l'émission on l'a entendu un
notamment dans la première partie vous
fondez l'armure c'est ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes
définitivement candidats à la primaire
non je ne suis pas définitivement
candidats puisque je n'ai pas encore
déclarée une candidature de ce qu'est ce
que vous êtes aujourd'hui quand non mais
si jamais un processus collectif ce que
j'ai dit et je le redis avant la session
les collectifs en asie un processus
collectif se met en place les
communistes pas pierre leurrons pas ce
que ça ne sera pas une décision
personnelle dans les communistes auront
à se poser une question à ce moment là
est-ce qu'il soutienne un candidat ce
qu'ils on présente à ce moment là on se
posera cette question mais d'abord il
faut travailler
est-ce que vous avez envie mais moi j'ai
envie de représenter mes idées sinon je
serais pas secrétaire nationale du parti
communiste y aller donc j'ai forcément
envie que mes idées soit présente dans
le débat qu'elle soit défendu qu'elles
soient défendues mais je ne suis pas le
sol non plus à pouvoir les cas on
attendra on attendra réjouit c'est bien
que ça de la bonne réponse vous sera pas
actif
ça vous ça vous dérange parce que c'est
des îles il ya des codes et vous vous
pensez que c'est forcément obligé de
passer par c'est qu'au delà pour être
efficace tout ça alors on attend à voir
je crois ce que je dis c'est à dire le
collectif d'abord ok pour décider ce
jour de champ d'atora merci merci merci
à tous bon soirée semaine prochaine nous
serons au salon de l'agriculture mon
soir
il